brown bears like they're like just
gentler they're like betas okay I
wouldn't say that brown bears like eat
berries and like they're like oh they're
just like whoa you're gonna be thinking
about this when you're walking up the
trail next week and you're like he's
just in front of you like oh so I'm a
[__] right what'd you say oh song like
berries right no first no you're sure
boys oh you're the one that said we only
like berries right and then one other
boys walks out behind you with a with a
Paw full of berries and he mushes it on
your forehead yeah yeah and he starts
rubbing it all over your head and he's
like yo boys I think we found a big
blueberry right here no we don't we
don't eat humans at all but blueberries
we definitely do eat those thank God
what we're seeing right now is a big old
blueberry you're not a human right no
I'm a I'm a blueberry louder full so all
my boys can hear you I'm a blueberry
nah we're just [__] with you bro but
watch your [__] mouth yeah and then
they also walk away yeah yeah and I'm
like I [__] knew it